ننوه بهذا الخبر نقلا عن صحيفه معاريف
الاسرائيليه والذي تنقل عن مدير مستشفى
برزيلاي
يقول عالجنا اكثر من
3500 جريح منذ السابع من اكتوبر وهو رقم
لم نشهده من قبل اذا هذا الخبر نقلا عن
مدير مستشفى برزيلاي
اذا الان ننتقل لضيفنا من الخليل عادل
شديد الباحث المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي
مثل لنبدا بهذا الخبر الذي نوهنا عنه للتو
يعني
عندما يعني تصل هذه المعلومات للشارع
الاسرائيلي تباعا يعني هذه اول مره هذا
العدد من المصابين القتلى المخطوفين ما
الى ذلك كل هذا هل
يؤثر فعليا ويؤدي الى نزول نتنياهو عن
شجره
الاستعلاء صباح الخير لك استاذه ليلى
وللمشاهدة
[موسيقى]
بمستشفى سوروكا في بئر السبع ايضا استقبل
يعني الاف اكثر من 2500 مصاب اعتقد من
بدايه الحرب الحاليه ثم عشرات المستشفيات
الاخرى وقبل اسبوعين بيوم السبت كان حديث
كان على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي سكان
اسرائيليين يسكنون بجوار مستشفى اخلف بتل
ابيب التي تبعد 100 كيلو عن غزه تحدثوا
انه كل نصف ساعه تسقط طائره هليكوبتر
تنقل مصابين من ساحه المعارك بغزه بالتالي
اي هه الارقام اولا تعمق يعني شكوك
المجتمع اليهودي بالارقام والبيانات التي
تصدر عن القياده العسكريه عن الناطق
العسكري
اليومي
وبخصوص الاجابه عن السؤال هل انه من
الممكن ان تغير ه
الارقام اندفاعيه و وزخم الحرب من وجهه
نظر اسرائيليه وخاصه انه هي اول حرب
بتاريخ الحركه الصهيونيه ان تحظى بدعم من
100% من المجتمع
اليهودي بتقديري انه الذي سيؤدي الى
تغيير دعم المجتمع الاسرائيلي وهذا
لاحظناه بالاسبوعين الماضيين
هو الارتفاع
الكبير بالقتلى وبمصاحبة
تقدم يعني لو كان هنالك تقدما وانجاز ولو
كانت يعني البيانات التي تصدر عن الجيش
والمستوى السياسي بانهم حققوا ودمروا
وقتلوا لو كان ذلك صحيح من الممكن ان
يستمر الاسرائيلي ب ه هذه ايضا قناعه جانس
وجالت والتي ادت الى مقاطعتهما بالامس
لمؤتمر الصحفي هذا بحد ذاته يرسل رساله
قويه اليس
كذلك استاذه ليلى اليوم التطور الاخطر في
النقاش الاسرائيلي الداخلي ما بين يعني
يعني المستوى العسكري والمستوى السياسي ان
المستوى العسكري بات يشك في انه نتنياهو
حين حدد هذه الاهداف كان يحي تماما انها
غير قابله للتحقيق والترجمه والتنفيذ
بالميدان وبالتالي اراد ان يظهر بان الجيش
ضعيف وان الجيش الاسرائيلي اليوم هو ليس
الجيش الاسرائيلي القديم وان يتنصل
نتنياهو من مسؤولياته وانه هو الذي ادى
الى تمزيق المجتمع الاسرائيلي باجراءات
بتغييرات
القانونيه وال والديمقراطيه
بال بالعام الماضي بالتالي الجيش الان بدا
يشعر بالجديه انه كان بالبدايه انه من
الممكن انه صدمه السابع من اكتوبر افقدت
الجيش والمخابرات والحكومه والمجتمع صوابه
واتزانه وذهب بهذا الاتجاه بدون بدون اي
تفكير بدون بدون اي حسابات لها علاقه
بالامكانيات والمحددات وما يمكن تحقيقه
وما لا يمكن تحقيقه ولكن ال بعد فتره تبين
انه انه نتنياهو كان يعي انه من الصعب
تحقيق وترجمه
هي الاهداف اليوم هنالك احتمال كبير انه
نتنياهو يعي تماما عدم قدره الجيش على
تحقيق ذلك بالتالي يريدها باتجاهين تبرير
استمراريه الحرب التي لا يريد وقفها
نتنياهو وشركاه وليس فقط بحسابات شخصيه
ايضا الحسابات حزبيه مرتبطه بحزب اللكود
وقف الحرب اليوم وقف الحرب اليوم يعني
خساره ما تبقى من حزم بالكود امام المجتمع
اليهودي في ظل عدم قدرته على تحقيق
الاهداف
والسبب الاهم من ذلك اليوم باتت النخبه
العسكريه تشك انه يراد توريطها في في ازمه
تفقد النخبه العسكريه تاثيرها بالحياه
وبالسياسة
توقيت لبايدن الانتخابات على الابواب
وهناك توقيت
لحماس اي من هذه التوقيتات برايك سينجح في
فرض
نفسه يعني حتى اللحظه و باعتراف الكثير من
الخبراء والمتابعين العسكريين لما يحدث
بالميدان من الاسرائيليين انه واضح تماما
انه حماس اعدت نفسها كثيرا لهذه المعركه
الطويله وحتى اللحظه لا يبدو اي تراجع في
الهرم القيادي والتسلسل القيادي لحركه
حماس وكيفيه قيادتها للمعركه الاعلاميه
والميدانيه و والتفاوض ثم انه من حيث
القدرات حتى اللحظه يعني لا تبدو انه
قدرات حركه حماس العسكريه والمقاومه قد
تراجعت او او تم المس بها والدليل انه قبل
الايام كان في تقرير يقول انه
45% من قدرات وامكانيات الوحدات المختاره
النخبه بالجولان وبالقفا تضررت وخرجت من
الخدمه سواء بالقتل او الاصابه او تدمير
المعدات بينما التقديرات عندهم انه قدرات
حركه حماس لم تتراجع اكثر من 20% وان
الاكثريه من ال 20% كانوا قد فقدوها في
اليوم الاول للحرب بالسابع من اكتوبر
ببدايه معركه طوفان الاقصى لذلك واضح
تماما و باقرار اسرائيلي انه حتى اللحظه
حركه حماس تدير المعركه باقتدار وفي ظل
يعني زياده وتعمق الازمات الداخليه سواء
ثقه المجتمع الاسرائيلي بالحكومه
وانهيارها وتحديدا بالرئيس ثقه المستوى
السياسي الداخليه ازمه السياسيين
والعسكريين وبالمناسبه يعني بالامس كان
التطور لافت انه وزير الدفاع الذي ينتمي
الى نفس حزب اللكود الذي يراسه نتنياهو
اصطفى مع مع مع مع جنس ولم يحضر المؤتمر
الصحفي وهذا يعي يعني يشار له باكثر من من
اتجاه الاول انهم قرروا ان لا يبقوا شهود
زور عند نتنياهو وان لا يستخدمهم ك كشما
وغطاء و و وحامي لسياسات ويبدو ثمق نعم
اكمل جملتك لو سمحت بس ثم ايقنوا تماما
انه ان لم يتم وضع النقاط على الحروف امام
نتنياهو وتحديدا
مساله بقاء الجيش بغزه ومرحله ما بعد
الحرب في غزه انه نتنياهو قد يؤدي الى خلق
واقع جديد في غزه تجد اسرائيل نفسها غير
قادره على الخروج كما اوصفوا وصفوه
بالاعلام العبري قبل ايام بان نحن امام
تجربه لبنان رقم اثنين في التور
وربما هذا ما بدات تدركه واش كذلك وسنرى
طبعا تاثير الزياره القادمه للكن الاسبوع
القادم شكرا جزيلا لك الاستاذ عادل شديد
الباحث المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي شكرا
لك